[Applaudissements]
non c'est pas c'est un bras de fer entre
olivier minne qui est magnifique
olivier minne a tout vous dire c'est 120
kg de bonheur autres mokhtar 120 kilos
de muscles rap us
combien 120 130 130 voix las vegas quand
même pas trop m kg élevés 94 94 et qu'on
peut voir un mec combien tu es bon on
peut arrêter un rookie alors la plus on
ne peut plus là donc vaut 94 84 danse
kilos pour 1 mètre 80 et evo comme 1,90
pardon avait 90 ans en train de thilo
ouais d'accord il fait la même taille
que vous c'est fou 35 kg de moi à la
fois même un bras attention vos stars
c'est tous les deux droitiers
c'est à moi de faire le bois de fer que
tout le monde a strange alcudia jalal
goût de tous tu es bien que ça va
beaucoup de mon temps on dirait là je
dirais la vénus de milo qu'ils ont su
attention c'est parti
stop oh la la allez y les bars et attend
sur le coude le coup d'attention de la
part langues sur la table le coup trois
tables sont secs mon courroux mama dans
ta gueule
[Rires]
bonjour alors allez-y c'est parti mais
il va me raser
[Applaudissements]
il
je suis content j'ai fait exprès bien
entendu et la semois la semoy voit pas
que ta face et de mal comme celle ci
après est ce que tu as fait olivier et
là sans merci mon bébé